hey guys great over here John here so we
just did a trailer reaction for the
latest Blade Runner trailer later in
2014 ein and uh okay so we got a look at
a few more things yeah we got here very
lettuce Nicolas Cage impression it
sounds fantastic
trying to protect our eyes or protector
yeah into the future I feel like we got
to see a lot more people and got to hear
a lot more people speak in this truth
yeah we did and we got better insight
into who Jared Leto is it has this line
about how every great civilization was
built on the backs of slaves then you're
hearing about how it sounds like that
his whole goal is to make replicas the
future of civilization because in the
first blade runner' her replicants are
outlawed and here it sounds like he's
building more and more and you want them
to be the predominant race the feature
race yeah or some kind of halfway step
between full-on representin and human or
something like that you know yeah the
way they're being developed looks
interesting especially from the other
trailers they looked a little different
the trailer posed a lot of questions too
you know there's that line that you're
loved saying that doing the way the
trailer slices it together makes it look
like Jared Leto saying he has a walk to
something and Ryan Gosling is that she
has the key to whatever the thing is
that nearly was after and the question
is what are they talking about
specifically what does Ryan Gosling
happen what is his special thing as a
Mendez Everman you have a shame because
yeah where she bid we got to get teams
gotta get to Eva Mendes we need the
hottest replicate we could make right
now I think also the other question too
that's posed when Ryan Gosling is asking
why I'm being hunted in hair spores that
brings up some questions - I mean I
wonder if they're gonna finally put a
nail in the coffin of the debate about
the first movie with that well if you do
any research on it Ridley Scott and
Harrison Ford
greatly disagree on it they kept doing
cuts and Harrison Ford is like now he's
not a replica
he even tells Ridley Scott like no he's
not a replica and really Costa will own
the directors my story if you knew the
replicas okay Marisa more just thinks is
stupid and I heard that there were
arguments that took place on set of this
one group about story-wise and where to
go and I'm pretty sure that's why
they're gonna kill us
Harrison Ford we could stop arguing it
was replicator human he's dead now maybe
the questions being posed because that's
the official reveal right they're like
well we're on the run because I'm also a
replicant who managed to figure out the
hole for your lifespan aging gap but
maybe his girl Rachel wasn't able to
figure it out on you now I just lose
alone old old robot in old man Harrison
for oh man for general dusty glass
apartment yeah how do you from that you
afford such a nice place being on the
run well is because it looks like
rundown nice like it looks like it used
to be nice but not that's like daddies
evacuated like this I wouldn't use that
nicest place in tonight nice place in
the worst part of town yeah keep this
way Queen to old man yeah it's ramping
up the mystery is you know this trailer
doesn't give you or I didn't feel like
it gave me a whole lot cig my teeth into
really other than questions I'm excited
to see the movie to get answers to yeah
I think that's a good trailer I feel
like some people might walk away with
his trailer thinking oh the trailer
spoiled a lot I don't think so because
what this trailer does is it gets you to
go in with questions and that you want
to have answered yeah they don't make
anything pitch perfect clear on what's
going on yeah other than the fact that
maybe the Stila maybe is like is Jared
Leto theater it seems like he's the
official antagonist for this story is
his goal really to make replicas and
seeing the future of civilization that's
what it seems like so the trailer seems
like it's alluding to I would hope that
they'd be a little bit more than I'd
actually be a little upset I walk into
the theater and I'm watching the movie
I'm like how the trailer did give all
this way yeah any you know I certainly
hope that that doesn't happen I feel
like right now I don't think I want to
see any more I think this is enough for
me doesn't come out to like like several
buzz around yeah that's over so I
imagine where to get like a final
trailer at
point if it is a male director so really
it's a teaser and official and another
official trailer and a behind-the-scenes
featurette several months or four
October I'd imagine a good early at
least one more trailer and I don't want
them to I'm right there with you but I
feel like people might forget about it
you know yeah as long as I guess I just
don't want to see any more out of this
movie I think this came to the right
line for me where I'm like okay I've met
a lot of the characters now I get a
broader sense for the world in the
direction the plot is heading at least a
couple of questions this is going to
want to ask an answer over the course of
its runtime and now I'm glad that I have
it in this vague for yeah I don't quite
know what it all means and nothing I can
extrapolate from this and I'm not going
to go back and scour the trailer on
times but like nothing I've taken away
from this is making me go I definitely
know what's going to happen you know and
I'm good I'm glad about that
well this trailer definitely amped up
action aspects through that as opposed
to the other ones and the first wave
runner doesn't really have action in it
and we think of like two scenes that had
some action in it I see I wonder if
they're going to make like this kind of
halfway between Jason Bourne and Blade
Runner because you know you're abot that
fight in the beginning where he gets
like crunched through a wallet ISA yeah
and then he's like cooking food later on
in the trailer and it's you know yeah oh
yeah where they're out and I get a
wasteland garbage land yeah and in the
and air tart man Janis and and later Sal
it looks like there's a lot more action
in this one than the other one and it
also feels like there's probably a lot
more at stake here because it seems like
they're dealing with a future world
problem yeah as opposed to you know
because in the first one's just an
investigation story and he's trying to
hunt down specific replicants it's
dealing with that here it seems like
they're dealing with like humanities at
stake in this one yeah I feel like
there's a lot of like kind of nature of
the world stuff in the first one and
this feels to me like what's the outcome
now like we're up against something big
she said that at one point like world
this is you could buy we're buying a war
or something like that a with this so it
doesn't seem like the stakes have gotten
big and broad yeah and and like there
affect a lot of people yeah I hope it
doesn't get too big I hope it stays
within the realm of you know like while
this movie does need its thrills it is
decades later where audiences do want
that especially the first later wasn't
considered a massive hit when it first
came out
and if Warner Brothers is going to
invest their money into doing a sequel
for fans that are going to want to like
well we need to make sure more people
than just fans you're watching yeah yeah
and I get why they're pushing it so hard
during summertime especially you know
because it has all of the crazy imagery
you want during the number time and yeah
this is just all the things we've seen
all the things we've heard I feel like
they have everything they need to make
something that lives up to the original
one and now I just hope that they do but
it also looks emotionally intense yeah I
mean you got a lot of characters who are
freaking out in this trailer free get
out there in despair and it feels like
we're going to explore a lot more
territory new tech job it seems like
he's flying around to a lot more places
than just a couple of locations like the
first one yeah so I probably a lot more
world exploration here the questions I
am interested to see answered I wonder
how this is going to conclude yeah is it
going to be like a 3 or 3 rise of the
machines kind of way where they don't
prevent Judgment Day and they lose the
humans lose in the end the bitter ending
I D care supports definitely going to
die I hope he does I would love that if
they keep tilling off his old characters
ha ha ha
just go back to every property and make
sure they're all dead I'm kind of
worried about Jared Leto's performance
to be honest yeah a little bit I just
don't want this to become a ghost in the
shell' situation where it's like I like
a guy outside right now yeah hate him
wow it's getting louder
we hold to this with all the aspirations
this movie has like it looks dazzling
visually it looks intriguing story wise
like it looks like an awesome movie code
and it's got all the right people
involved so I hope this doesn't come out
as one of those it's just cool
yeah movies and you know yeah I kind of
worry about Jared Leto also and maybe
his performance will make a lot of sense
of the movie but every now and again
that will happen where somebody does
like goes really hardcore on an odd kind
of character and the M sometimes it's
distracting so like that sad yeah I'm
excited for the film and I like the
music that they have playing in this
trailer and Ryan Gosling looks like he's
gonna really hold his own in this film I
don't know about ISA as character is but
you're gonna kick put him in a movie you
got to have them slamming people yeah it
seems like I hope you have the same
exact attitude as Drexel yeah he doesn't
understand a lot of bleh I hope he it's
a replicator just doesn't get a lot of
human colloquialisms and stuff
everything is very literal I think he's
would be good comic relief help him in
the rocket a star in a movie together
one day oh just two big dudes being
charming or more wrestlers turned
everything yeah all right guys what do
you think of the Blade Runner 2049
latest trailer leave your comments down
below you can subscribe at the real
rejects click that notification belt
shout out to me and that's John Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram
shout out to my month go check out our
patreon for all the exclusive perks and
rewards and anything you contribute goes
directly to this channel keeping running
and of course you get rewards as well
take care
perk